tomorrow night on mystery theatre
Jessica marble faces for most dangerous
mystery yet who put their balls in the
potato salad tell me mr. Johnson why are
you testing rules covered in mayonnaise
was they were hot I was given the moral
pleasure and this morning guess what was
in my teeth salary just because I put my
dick in the coleslaw's does not mean I
put my balls in the potato sound who put
their balls in the potato salad I'll
just have the chips this is my podcast
is it just me or the commercials on TV
really pushing interracial dating it's
kind of ridiculous I seen a commercial
my first reaction is I want cheetos my
second reaction is I should date a black
guy jus I mean if every commercial has a
white girl dating a black guy what am I
supposed to feel I mean at first I want
a cheesy snack but then I start thinking
maybe my digs too small let's go to
affect purchases jus whether or not i
buy cheese doodles has nothing to do
with the fact cheese doodles supports
interracial dating I mean nobody is at a
candy counter going should we get the
chunky or should we get the peppermint
patty I mean the peppermint patty
supports Chinese guys [ __ ] Indian
woman but chunky supports lesbians with
strapons [ __ ] a Puerto Rican I can't
decide monkeys this is my podcast we'll
be right back after these messages do
you suffer from pants cancer I'm very
sorry mr. giraud but it appears you have
pants cancer ah [ __ ] does your shirt
have AIDS your shirt has AIDS what your
shirt has AIDS Oh what should I do I
don't know maybe change shirts how's
this one better but that one has
diarrhea Oh does your necktie have down
syndrome why is your tie all [ __ ] up
it's [ __ ] then you might be insane
go see a doctor and now back to this is
my podcast haze Brian scleral this is my
podcast and oh my god somebody's on my
door I just hang on one second yeah hi
Fred ok that wasn't me ok I didn't rat
you out listen you took a [ __ ] in the
elevator who's everybody gonna think it
was they're gonna think it's you cuz
you're the monkey me you think I took a
[ __ ] in the elevator why would I take a
[ __ ] in the elevator
just because I'm fat me I doesn't mean I
can't make it to the toilet all right I
took a [ __ ] in the elevator I'm sorry
you got in trouble for I just couldn't
make it to the toilet all right hi I'm
taco bell you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you [ __ ] you
Jesus Christ how is it that a monkey has
that apartment you know I should call
the the [ __ ] animal control or the
immigration guys I don't know [ __ ]
monkey
and skunk in the
steak and a half
ah you know not everybody likes my
podcast in fact most people i've never
even heard it but out of the three who
have one had a real problem so i had her
on to talk about it your show is
offensive your show is rude your show is
disgusting and crude and dirty and
vulgar it's like having anal sex with a
big pile of dog [ __ ] Jesus that's a lot
worse than anything I had to say so far
who are you we demand that you be taken
off the internet there's a guy blowing a
zebra on the internet Laurie my name is
Regan Formica I represent pip hot bus
with what the papas pw p abs people well
actually person against ryan Scolaro
pip-pop bus we're thinking of shortening
it should i mean it's a kind of
ridiculous the people well person thing
could just be person why would you even
put a mistake in the name I don't
understand that and I think it could
just be PA BS you know person against
Brian Scolaro it's that kind of humor
that got you in trouble mr. got you in
trouble guide due to humor boy what mr.
got you in trouble to humor trouble
things guy what the [ __ ] I'm no good at
names alright what what exactly is your
problem with our show okay we meeting
you have narrowed the offenses down to
the five ours curses toilet sex and
penis that's you I don't think any of
those even started with an R what and
there were only four what and penis
would fall into the header of sex that's
really three oh shut up you suck you
know that man I'm gonna protest this
protest what yeah I mean that you got no
sign yeah no catchy slogan you got
nothing well what can I do you get up
get something like that rhymes you know
is I'm that's catchy okay let me try one
right hey hey Brian scolaro you look
like a [ __ ] you how is that could be
better a popular folk instrument in
Latin America this variety of xylophone
originated in Africa
who's Jessica Tandy correct and now the
news for Brian hello lion Brian scolaro
Brian Scolaro has the night off on top
story tonight Brian gave his number to a
19 year old waitress here's Brian with
the story thanks Brian it seems while he
was performing stand-up at this
restaurant in the valley of los angeles
Brian gave his number to a 19 year old
waitress now is he aware that he's 42
years old yes he is and is he also aware
that a 19 year old would view him as a
monster I believe he is but that didn't
stop him he's full of confidence the
least for that 10 seconds what was the
waitresses reaction she was very kind so
she liked him I wouldn't say that she
was kind in the sense that like when you
volunteer your time at a senior citizens
home and an old man wants to play
checkers you kind of let him win it was
like that she sounds very nice Brian
could certainly use somebody like her in
his life but unfortunately the last
thing she needs is somebody like Brian
in hurley very true very true and what
did she do afterwards well she put it in
her purse and then afterwards she got
home and forgot it was in her purse hey
where's the number now still in the
purse so she's keeping it now she it's
just kind of like underneath some
tampons and what did Brian do afterwards
I think we both know what he did
afterwards appalled yeah I guess we do
coming up after the break Brian gives
his number to the teenage girl working
the window let McDonald's
all right everybody the meeting is
called to order first we also thank my
wife for making all this delicious
lemonade thank you thank you my handsome
you first order of business Jay has
something to say Jay yes mm-hmm I peed
in the lemonade to make a motion that we
do not let Jay near the lemonade all in
favor hi it's unanimous even jayvo
deferred which is weird all right
somebody make a note of that vote does
anybody want to make a note of that vote
we don't have any pens well we're gonna
need some pens you know what we should
make that the second order of business
we need more pens somebody write that
down anybody know huh now Jay will you
read the minutes from the last meeting
sure buy more pair what that's all it
says buy more pair kind of stops right
there hmm wonder what women by that next
order of business is we got to figure
out who this guy is why don't we just
ask him all in favor of asking who this
guy is say I hi go ahead and ask him Jay
who are you Jimmy he says his name's
Jimmy all right next order of business
how did Jimmy get in here how'd you get
in here the front door okay next order
business somebody lock the front door
okay alright so now Carl was gonna tell
us how we did last year Carl as you can
see from this chart here where it's a
straight line which means we didn't do
anything we didn't buy anything we don't
sell anything we don't have any ideas of
any sort so we just break even except
for lemonade what did the analysts say
he said please get away from me I'm not
an analyst I'm a mailman please stop
chasing me why are you beating me please
ow oh my god it hurts so much oh I can't
breathe girl I gotta wonder what he
meant by that so Jimmy what's your take
on this I think we should rob a bank
yeah idea all right let's do it Carl
you'll to get away man find a really
fast car
j having it pay
I saw Jesus in the bathtub
Jesus was washing his penis
I did faint when he scrubbed his thing
honestly in all as I watched Jesus wash
his balls and the space tethers leg
Santa Steve and his arms an estate and
assault against Jesus was in the bathtub
some reason I gotta have just
I think us cause is not as finance
anywheres nothing oh my god him there
son I have junk this is not a bad oh
Jesus in my head and that was Jesus in
my bathtub by brians claro now Brian
what was the meaning behind that song
well it's uh it's about a guy who saw
Jesus in his bathtub grain and for some
reason he got erect I see now upon first
listen you would think this song is
going to be about you finding Jesus well
it is i do find Jesus yes but it makes
you sexually excited well he's a really
fit guy and he's got the long hair so he
has like a feminine thing about them you
know now the later part of the song
where you have sex with Jesus in your
bathtub right do you don't you think
that's a bit sacrilegious no no i don't
why is that because i was the bottom if
I had made Jesus the bottom then that
would be offensive I see
don't play low
don't take off love
okay next on 60 minutes Joe DeRosa talks
to a doctor who claims to have invented
teleportation and how did you invent
teleportation well it's it that matter
than the success it t yeah like I want
to get in that strip club but I have no
money how do I get in right and at first
I saw the big in tunnels right and then
things would fall down and there was
rats everywhere and it's a lot of
pooping down there yeah you don't
realize when you look at the floor
there's a lot of poop down there yeah
your biggest problem to invent
competition is the strip club scenario I
find if you're jerking off on the corner
or the driven off in a strip club or
drug it off in a movie theater then if
people show up they go stop that guy and
then poof I'm back home when they come
what I think it would be an easier
solution rat is to just not masturbate
in public did they tell Beethoven to
stop writing songs no but his songs
didn't create a mess I guess seaman
would be the thing that was missing from
Beethoven that made it a little more
acceptable I'm a little you know I've
never said this to one of my guests
before but I'm a little skeptical that
you've actually invented teleportation
as you didn't I could do it right now
you could I could tell the past Tommy
way you want me the goal and I'll go
then come back i justjust over to their
to the kitchen okay do me a favor close
your eyes for like about two minutes
haha alright Dave they weren't close
they're open I see you walking you
wrought you what I don't know I listen
I'm going to get the teleportation
machine really yeah I don't want you to
see what I hate it okay I mean you're
not even a fast Walker could you close
your eyes again please okay okay my eyes
are closed stop you you're just
masturbating why you met
okay that brings us to the end of
another episode this is my podcast thank
you very much for listening please share
with your friends please follow us on
soundcloud subscribe to us on iTunes
retweet it on Twitter I could use the
help once you rate my podcast on iTunes
they'll be very nice if you are in Los
Angeles I am all over this [ __ ]
for the next month and you can catch me
in Tucson at laughs in the first week in
the March special thanks to Carol Turner
and Joe DeRosa for appearing in this
episode oh and you can also catch me on
the newest episode of this TV show
doesn't exist on abcdefg have a good
night